- Oh my God, I love your outfit!
- Thank you.
- Those are the pants I
love 'cause you can just go
(blows raspberry) and they're off.
- (laughs) You can.
- Yeah, those are the button ones, right?
(Seal makes air whooshing noise)
Those are the, yeah.
You know, like the
button ones on the sides,
like when you play sports.
Anyway, I love those, it's
nice to see you again.
- Nice to see you again, yeah.
- We haven't seen each other,
I think we met and we were doing something
with David Foster for Indy-
- That was it, something he roped us into.
- He did, yeah, and we showed up, but we,
it was a race situation
that we both knew a lot about. (chuckles)
- Can you remember song we were singing?
What? What were we singing?
- I don't, it was it?
It wasn't like the "Star Spangled Banner"
or anything, was it?
- No.
- No? It wasn't something-
- Something, was it? Oh.
- 'Cause they do that
at some of those events.
- It was good fun though.
- We totally, it was
memorable for both of us,
we can't remember what we sang. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
It was so long ago, I mean,
like, probably 2004 or 2005.
- Yeah, probably at least-
- Yeah.
- At least 16, 17 years ago.
- Yeah, it was a while back.
Anyway, your voice is incredible.
I was so honored-
- Oh, thank you.
- To get to sing with you.
I love, there's people that can sing,
like, I feel like I'm a singer,
but you have, you're like a stylist.
You have that tone
that everybody recognizes
right off the bat.
You know, it's so special.
- Oh, you're not so bad yourself.